this is star talk sports edition and you
guessed it this is a FIFA World Cup
special
and we we've got Gary Gary O'Reilly oh
dude are you are you getting Gary
hey uh getting there getting there okay
we're getting there yeah cause this
thing's already just begun so all right
at the time of this recording only a few
games have been played uh out in Qatar
and all right and Gary's like feeling it
because this the man this was what he
did professionally yeah Chuck this is
not what you did professionally no this
is not uh however uh I I uh I am one of
the governing members of FIFA okay
so just know that I I too am excited
because uh let's just say that there's a
couple more zeros in my bank account
and you're going to make up some crazy
rule that people will complain about
later all right absolutely we got you so
Gary what have you cooked up for us
today all right um as we've just
discussed the World Cup is underway this
year it is in Qatar um maybe The
Greatest Show on Earth along with the
Olympics but each tournament
the sportswear giant Adidas
design a new ball so uh what is
interesting about a new ball you ask and
it's a fair question
um firstly the material science will
have changed uh the number of panels
will have changed their sake will have
changed the seams that connect them
will have changed there'll be a unique
pattern on the surface which is an
intentional construction
all of this will change the physics and
the aerodynamics of the ball therefore
the style of football that can be played
in this Qatar World Cup now for someone
to know all of this they've had to put
it in a wind tunnel throw a whole load
of equations at it and come up with a
whole load of results and conclusions
and that someone is a dear friend of
ours Professor Eric Goff and for those
of you yes professor and for those of
you who don't know Eric Goff I'll need a
refresher here we go he is Professor
Eric Goff professor of physics at the
University of Lynchburg in Virginia with
expertise in quantum mechanics and
classical mechanics author of gold medal
physics which is a scienceized view of
sporting greatness as well as another
publication the physics of Krav Maga he
is a first degree black belt in karate a
purple belt in Krav Maga which is an
Israeli military martial art so uh the
basic fact here is don't mess with the
Prof the good professor professor Eric
Goff lovely to have you back sir glad to
be back on Star Talk yeah it'll be
talking about the beautiful game here so
Eric just a curious thing here in in the
design Universe it seems to me something
such as a ball should achieve design
maturity by now yet apparently not so
are they just changing it up just to
change it up was there real advances in
this and are those advances something
you can detect and measure with your
tools the physics Adidas has had the
contract for the World Cup ball since
1970 and all the way up until 2002 and
including 2002 we had the traditional 32
panel ball and in the old days in 1970
the pentagons and hexagons were black
and white so you could actually see the
ball in a black and white television
all the way up till today of course
everybody's got phones and color
televisions and and you don't need that
kind of color scheme but the beauty of
having a new World Cup ball is the
country who's hosting gets to name it
there's a color scheme and they get to
come out with a new uh surface design
and as we heard these things 150 160
dollars uh they fly off the shelves for
the World Cup so there's a reason why a
company like Adidas wants to make a new
ball every four years
um and of course the goal is to make a
bowl that's round and round
is what a great starting point hey your
ball must be round okay
well think about how challenging that
was to put pentagons and hexagons
together into this kind of buckyball
Epcot Center shape
yeah yeah all right all right and now
you've got these crazy petal shapes
where it looks like you need a degree in
topology in order to put one of these
things together other so these
interlocking pedals the pedal numbers
change the surface textures changed but
the main point is this right here is the
most important piece of equipment in the
most important sporting event in the
world's most popular sport so it has to
behave in ways that players are familiar
with you can't
as what happened in 2010 you can't dump
a ball out onto the pitch and it's
behaving in ways that they're not used
to
so so there's some standards so so
they're physics standards within which
if you fulfill them everything else is
just window dressing is that correct
so there are certainly aerodynamic
properties that you would like to happen
I'd like to have with the ball so that
it flies in ways the players are
familiar with but as far as that goes if
you can make the panels and arbitrarily
crazy looking shapes and the surface
texturing be it a certain way to create
a certain roughness for the ball
as long as it behaves in the aerodynamic
ways the players are used to it's a good
Bowl so what happened in 2010
so we have this lovely fact in physics
that seems counterintuitive that if you
take a ball and you smooth it you polish
it you actually increase the Air drag on
it at a given speed the roughness of the
bowl is very important so things like
baseball with those lovely 108 double
stitches and the 330 odd dimples on a
golf ball that that roughness helps
lower the drag at given speeds so what
happened in 2010 the pedal number from
2006 so the team dice ball at 14 dropped
to eight
so you only had eight panels on the
jabalani bowl
but it turned out to be even with some
surface texturing it was too smooth
so this lovely drag crisis that we talk
about in physics where the high speed
flow of air around the ball that we call
turbulent flow transitions to a lower
speed that we call laminar and the drag
coefficient skyrockets and that happened
at two largest speed in fact around 50
miles an hour is where this transition
happens so what would happen with a
javalani and I don't have one with me
but the jabalani would be flying through
the air it would pass around 50 miles an
hour the transition of the air around it
would go from turbulent to Lavender the
drag coefficient would Skyrocket and the
ball would look like it's just slowing
too fast almost like a beach ball that
you'd hit really hard and it would just
seem to slow very quickly so it had a
very erratic flight the players were not
used to it and Adidas has not made that
same mistake the the bersooka that was
used in Brazil the Telstar 18 in Russia
and this year's Al reala all have a
aerodynamic profile all that are very
similar I got one last question before I
hand off to my co-host here so so
how long do teams have to practice with
the brand new ball for the New World Cup
so my understanding is they get a couple
of months and the fact is you can buy
this thing off the shelf so I mean
players can go and get a ball it's not
like it's uh you know only held until
the World Cup so they they could
certainly play with this thing even in
practice for 180 dollars in this economy
I don't think so okay this this
tournament is at sea level in Qatar if
it were say in Mexico and we were
playing in Mexico City we're at altitude
so we would acclimatize we'd be having
the work with the balls I mean even back
in my day in the 80s if we were playing
a team from another country in their
Stadium we would need to get the ball
that they used so we didn't walk out
onto the field and all of a sudden be
surprised by a ball that had a whole
different set of characteristics we knew
and we we will tell the difference we
could blind test all thoughts so for
instance the jabalani that Eric was
talking about would virtue if you hit it
at distance or with power as a shot on
goal
the thing would basically knuckleball
and goalkeepers weren't very happy uh
this then affects the coefficient goal
ratio within games which FIFA quite like
because there's a chance there's more
gold so therefore it's more entertaining
it's therefore better Global spectacle
in markets they're looking to explore
however the players didn't like it
because there's a long there's a long
history of long diagonal passes 60 yards
50 yards 40 yards and for that you're
gonna clock over the 50 mile an hour
speed when you hit the ball well let's
roll over yep yeah the accuracy
disappears so now all of a sudden if
your team is based upon a long ball game
a direct game forget it because now
you're having to play shorter your style
of football has changed
so now for the ball has become a
disadvantage to your style of football
and you're going to have to not just
evolve as an individual but evolve as a
team to be able to accommodate this ball
but Gary that's just that's just home
field advantage yeah no no there's no no
no home field advantage it's all of a
sudden you're predisposal
yeah but the thing is and you come into
a World Cup Tournament the ball is the
same for everybody so you take away that
it's whose style of football
suits this type of ball better is there
an individual that has a skill set that
works better to this particular type of
ball now what we need to get into is not
just the design aspect of it
but once you put it in a wind tunnel
what do you find out what have Adidas
done this time round that makes this
ball another jabalani or is it closer to
Bazooka or Telstar where are we going to
go because this will give us an idea of
the kind of thing that we might be
seeing as the games progress in the
tournament that's that's interesting
because that's something nobody quite
knows yet and it could have just be
there Adidas needs to make a hundred and
eighty dollars a bar every four years
because that's my vote do you actually
put these in Wind tunnels Eric
uh yeah I have colleagues at the
University of scuba in Japan and they
will put these things in Wind tunnels
and the sad thing is when you put one of
these this is the Bazooka when you put
this in a wind tunnel uh you have to
destroy it because you got to put a
support stake in in one side of it and
we can measure the forces felt when the
air is blowing over the ball we could
vary the air speed throughout the entire
range that uh players would be playing
uh the sport of soccer but you can't but
you don't it sounds like if you're
supporting it you can't spin it right I
was going to say how how do you get an
accurate measurement because there are
always been there are ways to spin it
where you have the Sting coming in from
the side and you can spin it we could
also do trajectory analysis where the
ball can be actually kicked or even shot
through a ball launcher with Spin and
then by analyzing the trajectory we can
extract the aerodynamic coefficients
from that right that sounds cool nice
it's very cool yeah and why can't you
just do all that digitally like just get
The Masks of the ball and the texture
here and everything and just just model
it the models are actually really uh
gotten quite nice but the computational
fluid dynamics is still just a little
bit behind where the wind tunnel results
are trying to actually get the
individual little textures and surface
features programmed into a cad file and
then have those things put into some
fluid software or whatever you're using
is still a bit of a challenge gotcha
what happens is when we used to have
those black and white 32 panel that was
all hand stitched now there's a whole
note thank you Bill is now no longer
leather balls there are no longer hand
stitching you've got a whole way of
thermocoupling these panels together
their shape their size the seam itself
has to be analyzed so as you know
exactly what this ball will do will it
knuckle at 40 50 60 miles an hour will
you be able to do anything with it what
you know how is it going to react and we
need to know these things hey do you
know this Gary because or or Eric uh
because all these bars used to be made
of leather like even baseball even
baseballs but now nobody does that it's
all synthetic with a bladder inside
separate baseball has a core what what
what what what do do you know what the
material is like what are what are they
covering that bladder with now what is
that what is the synthetic Eric I I
don't know the actual composition of
these I mean it's certainly just a
synthetic material is the is it is it
not a polyurethane and this new ball
that the alrilla which in Arabic stands
for the journey just so as you want to
know all right how romantic and it's
called speed chill it's called speed
shell speed shell yeah so you can
imagine there is a coating over the ball
I mean as far as I'm aware the
the inks that are used are water-based
the glues that are used to seal and
couple the panels are water-based so
they're more environmentally friendly
yeah yeah so hopefully it doesn't fall
apart in the rain so if you want to eat
the ball it's environmentally it's
organic
dude we got to take a quick break but
when we come back we're gonna get all in
on what Eric does with these balls
because I haven't I'm still trying to
figure that out all right this is
StarTalk sports edition FIFA World Cup
special we'll be right back
we're back star talk sports edition FIFA
World Cup special
and Gary's been getting the whole first
segment yeah we can't even shut them up
that's uh wait we got a guest here okay
it's talking
so so let's find out just a few more
things uh from our guest Professor uh
Eric Goff Professor uh when you should
be like doing your quantum physics why
are you worrying about soccer balls
oh there's a lot of there's a lot of
fascinating physics in these in their
balls yep no but there ain't no quantum
physics last I checked
well Bohr's correspondence principle
we've got to remember we got to take
quantum mechanics to the classical
levels so it's all quantum mechanics oh
yeah at the end of the day it's all the
end of the day but I also I really think
it's important to get a little bit of
science on the sports Pages a lot of
people who are interested in sports may
not get exposed to a lot of good science
ideas that's the whole point of StarTalk
sports edition exactly
the entire Point Gary uh Chuck you got
more questions for our man here yeah so
okay when you put this ball in a wind
tunnel um
what sort of speed will the arella begin
to knuckle and behave in an erratic way
because you've got to you've got to push
it outside of its envelope at some point
for for the testing to be accurate but
just to be clear
to say knuckle is to borrow a term from
baseball that's okay the ultimate source
of all other sports terms okay
we're borrowing from a good place no no
just to be clear I want to explain that
in case people don't know okay sorry so
a pitcher's throwing a knuckleball uh
their Knuckles are what touches the ball
not their fingertips and when they
release the ball because their
fingertips aren't touching the ball
there's less that the ball is less
likely to rotate and so the ball just
sort of moves without rotating which
makes it hugely susceptible to any wind
currents or anything going on between
the pitcher and The Catcher And often
the catcher
can't track the ball and there are a lot
of drop balls or pass balls or wild
pitches uh when that happens and so when
you say so uh Erica or Gary whoever
which of you said at the beginning where
uh many of the goalies could not track
the ball it wasn't following some so
this is a this is a total replication of
picture hitter the guy who's shooting at
gold as to opposed to the guy in in the
goal that's trying to save it if that
goalkeeper has the same scenario I don't
know where this is going up down left or
right you've got the replication of a
knuckleball and normal laws of physics
are not guiding you do you know of a
projectile right well certainly not the
the vacuum laws of physics and
kinematics but so when you throw a
knuckleball
the idea is you want like maybe a half
turn on the way to the plate so
with a little bit of roughness on one
side from a seam that can delay the
separation of the boundary layer on the
other side where it's a little smooth
the boundary layer will separate early
so the wake of air behind it gets
deflected to one side so just like a
boat Rudder moving the wake of water off
to the side
Newton's third law comes in if the air
is getting pushed by the ball one way
the ears got to push the ball the other
way so then when the ball rotates a
little bit and you get a little
smoothness on one side and a little
rough missile the other then you move
back toward the roughness so you get
that little wobble and the same thing
happens with the soccer ball where you
might have a little bit more of a rough
side with a little bit of a seam on the
face on the side here a little bit of a
smooth area over here and you can get a
little movement toward the rough side
and a little bit of rotation and you can
make these things wobble quite a bit so
if you're a player are you are you
telling me that you're able to learn how
to kick the ball to create that movement
the same way Neil talked about the
pitcher doesn't touch the ball you're
able to do that so Gary how do you do
that because that sounds insane okay so
we if you look at the profile of a
soccer ball and you went north south
east west right so you went the multiple
than an equator
depending on which quadrant you contact
with you can then impart the rotation
you can then if you're more Central to
that point where the pole and the
equator cross over you will drive on a
more
power through the ball and therefore
less rotation to either left or right
and then if you go underneath then you
put backspin if you come over the top
you can impart that forward spin now you
learn Eric is it fair to say that you
could kick the ball with the same speed
foot
and all that energy goes into the ball
but from what Gary is saying depending
on what quadrant either all the energy
will go to propel the ball forward or
some will do that and some will go into
the rotation
that that's right the if you kick it
right through the center of the bowl
you're you're at your linear impulse is
Big your angular impulse is small you
move it with a little bit more of a
lever arm away from the center you get
more of that torque to get the ball
rotating and you get those lovely banana
kicks
we will learn as we've discussed just
previously in the show each individual
ball and then we will learn to adapt our
skill on doing that to each individual
ball
um it's I mean okay here we go so Adidas
claimed that the arella is the fastest
ball of any of the World Cup balls that
they've designed
um you've stuck it in a wind tunnel
you've thrown the equations at it are
they telling the truth so in some
orientations uh that we've tested the
drag coefficient at a high speed is a as
a tiny bit smaller what we did notice is
that the drag coefficient at small
speeds so something in the 20 mile an
hour range uh was the smallest of the
World Cup balls that we had tested I
don't know if players are going to
notice that small change in the speed of
the ball with some of their intermediate
you know range passing but they could
notice a slight difference in that but
it's certainly at the high speeds there
is a reduction in the drag coefficient
but very very tiny it very much models
the drag curves we saw with the Telstar
18 and the Bazooka so it's Gary Wright
is it the fastest ball ever
if you have the lowest drag coefficient
it's the fastest bowler right or some
orientations I would say it's it's
faster than the other balls yes but not
for other orientations so it's a it's a
marketing it's basically a technical
marketing Point probably but I I can't
speak for Adidas's motivation other than
to say hey this ball is really cool I
mean and costs 180 right why not just
put 303 divots in it like we do golf
balls yeah
I I think making the a sphere this large
that's got to be inflated and have a
bladder like that is going to be a
little more challenging because you're
going to have to have you're still going
to need panels uh in fact the alveolar
ball uh unlike the texturing of past
balls is not coming out of the ball it's
not uh embossed it's debossed you
actually get the the texturing going
into the into the panels it looks like a
golf ball like like a golf ball it's it
you're absolutely right now they have
replicated a golf ball
now this has 20 panels uh you have these
eight triangular petals uh you get the
12 petals that look like drubsticks that
you used to get out of the freezer for
dessert uh those are the paddle shapes
that we have on the new ball so they
actually raised from six panels in the
last two World Cups all the way up to 20
but they made sure the roughness was the
same because they brought down the total
seam length the total seam length of
this fall uh it's only about six percent
longer than bazooka and bazooka had six
panels
I I'm stuck on Frozen drumsticks for
dessert
that's what those panels look like to me
so what difference what difference does
the panel shape make
apart from you know if you've got more
panels then you've got long you've got a
greater seam length but it then there
can't be just you know I'll make it a
drumstick no one will notice there has
to be a reason these things aren't just
thrown together at least I hope not
that's right so talking about bazooka
you know how did they fix this from the
job Hawaii disaster in 2010 so bazooka
has six panels you know they they it's
two fewer panels the jabalani but the
panel shapes follow these circuitous
lines it has a parallel total seam
length that was 68 longer than that on
jabalani despite two fewer panels the
seam widths the seam depths on bazooka
were it was wider it was deeper it's
also when you touch the seam and the
surface parts of the panels it feels
rougher so they raise the texturing on
it so they actually made the ball
rougher despite two fewer panels and
that's what made the drag crisis set a
smaller speed until star 18 that ball
that was used in Russia who is not
allowed to play with the current World
Cup participants because they helped
play well with their neighbors well this
ball right here has six panels as well
but very different shapes and it's total
seam length here is about 30 percent
longer than bazooka but to make it the
same amount of roughness that they took
the scene with the seam depth made it a
little less wide a little less deep the
texturing isn't quite as high it feels a
little bit smoother on the panel so all
these things are compensating when you
change the panel number you change the
total seam leak the seam width the seam
depth the texturing type all of that has
to be compensated in a way to give the
ball essentially the same roughness as
the previous fall it sounds like to me
they're just changing it to change it
absolutely it's not like they're making
it better they're just making it
different I agree I'll go back to
Chuck's point about this being a little
bit commercial or a lot commercial we've
got to repeat 180 okay go ahead give or
take it depends depends on your
preferred uh sports goods
place
um all right professor
we look at NFL and you see a quarterback
with a long Hail Mary pass and it's spin
stabilized and really quite accurate so
do we have
a concern about spin stability
with the new World Cup ball I mean do
you test for that because if we're going
to see not such a short passing game but
a longer diagonal press passing game
because in them in the modern game
there's a high press like in a
basketball a full court press so rather
than get caught up in there and lose
possession you bypass it with the long
diagonal pass a pass over the opposing
team which takes them out of the
equation so to do that you need accuracy
and if the ball just wibbles and Wobbles
and becomes this knuckleball beach ball
kind of affair have we tested for that
kind of spin stability on the arila
well certainly if if you're kicking a
knuckle ball it's not going to have a
lot of spin so you don't have the spin
stability there but the wet tunnel test
that we've done as I said before a
couple of orientations do look to have a
little bit more knuckling than some of
the previous balls some other
orientations not as much knuckling now
we're talking about an infinite number
of orientations that you could have that
ball facing the oncoming air
um and and you know players aren't going
to be able to ascertain whether the ball
they're about to kick is going to be in
one of those magic orientations or not I
mean it'll be rolling on the pitch and
then they're going to be kicking it down
uh at some long pass so it'll it I'm
definitely looking to see if there's
much knuckling going on at some of these
high-speed kicks is there is there any
team that will derive a benefit again
and some teams that will have a
detriment because of this ball like that
you know of off the top here because I
know both of you are really into you
know the the the game and the teams and
the competition well I'm hoping the US
team is young enough not to care about
it too much they're just going to kick
it and play with a lot of Reckless
abandon at times and uh a lot of energy
so uh you know I'd like to think that
our youth could at least uh prevent us
from worrying too much about the physics
of the bowl
in other words we're f'd because
the USA did just say that
is our team is not skilled enough that
this will make a difference so hopefully
no no I didn't say nuts I didn't say not
skilled enough I said I hope they're
young enough to not let that get in
their heads by skilled I mean
experienced enough but uh yeah the USA
are in the group in the group stage with
England Iran and Wales
um so there's a very good chance when
the USA haven't played yet as we're
recording this they haven't yeah the USA
will do very well in the group stage so
uh just to add to the professor's Point
there's a lot of encouragement there's a
lot of really really good talent in the
USA team so I don't think England will
be taking them for granted at all what I
would say Chuck in addressing your
question a team like Spain who
historically have a very short sharp
passing game
a team like Argentina
who basically play at times it's like
death by a thousand passes so they will
pass pass pass and in doing this they
distort an opposition they overload them
to create space in other areas and then
they make this very sharp penetrative
past those teams that played a shorter
passing game on the ground that will be
advantageous because if there's any kind
of wobbling and knuckling with the
longer passing if they're if their game
is supposed to do that a lot then that
game will then become less accurate Gary
just just influenced the Vegas odds yeah
recitation he's saying whoever with this
ball whoever who's ever game depends
mostly on short passes
will have an advantage
that's did that Eric did that sound like
that's what Gary well and the short pass
uh speeds the measure of drug
coefficients look like they're a little
smaller for Al reala compared to
previous balls so there could be a
slight increase in speed for somebody
it's feeding the speed Neil FIFA and and
with their best friend Adidas are
speeding the game up it's already got
faster and faster now when these short
passes that are passed along the surface
of the grass it gets even faster than
yeah then you really are testing A
team's defense you're testing a whole
lot of organization so it's it's you
know these are the minute little bits
and pieces that go into
understanding how this will take place
due to the fact that you've got a
different design of the ball oh yes so
we're going to take a quick break and
when we come back I'm going to start off
by asking Eric what about the valves on
the ball nobody's talked about things
I want to know and then we'll we'll chew
the fat on the beauty and Majesty of the
sport itself being so International and
so Timeless on StarTalk sports edition
the FIFA World Cup special
we're back StarTalk sports edition
FIFA World Cup special and Gary is giddy
because he was a former professional
soccer player Gary you played with who
over in the UK
um oh I put I didn't play international
level I played at Club level with
Tottenham with Crystal Palace and
Brighton and they are all currently
doing quite well in the English Premier
League so England's got a Fame you know
they're famous for their their premier
league right I mean I mean the English
invented the modern game of association
football however we are no longer any
good at it okay oh wow yeah we handed
that we handed that mantle over to the
Brazilians the Italian it was after he
left the sport that's when England
started going down the two most likely
so Eric uh we've spent all this time
talking about stitching and Pat and and
drumsticks from the refrigerator and
which distracted Chuck of and uh shapes
of the pen channels what about the valve
this seems to me to be a a profound
asymmetry in its structure and its
design
well the the valve setting in our real
actually appears to be a little bit more
recessed than some of the recent balls
so when you rub your finger over the
valve you could actually feel that
corner edging but it's actually quite
small and you know when you're looking
at the size of that valve it's only
perhaps about one and a half times the
width of the ceiling so it it it's not a
huge asymmetry on the bowl no no but it
has it doesn't weigh the same it's
something about a slight Mass asymmetry
yeah you've changed the mass
distribution of the ball
very slightly that's right
um we have we we haven't measured that
little change in mass asymmetry to see
what kind of effect that would have with
a spinning ball
so I I certainly couldn't talk to how
much that would have well I can ask Gary
Gary doesn't uh when the when they do a
a place kick or whenever the ball is
just sitting there do they align the
valve in one way or another it will
depend they can and they do if the ball
if the free kick right is more Central
then it's most likely a direct strike on
goal
um
if and I've seen players place the ball
meticulously and you realize I've seen
that I mean I'm just imagining it right
they are placing it so as the the
aperture of the valve is directly where
the contact of their foot will be uh
this then invariably ends up as a
knuckleball now there must be most
certainly a greater change in defamation
as for if you were to kick another part
of the surface now I would like to know
what the physics are behind contacting
what is a a vulnerable point on the ball
in terms of changing how things are
inside and obviously externally yeah
Eric you you let us down here without
having checked to check the valve what
what what what kind of amateur rank
amateur operations are you running it's
it's just funding that's all it is
oh man that's great answer good answer
yes best answer we don't have that that
middle east oil money to fund our
project here so well let's take spend a
minute just talking about Qatar as a
location we learned earlier that it's
sea level but are the temperatures going
to go high and when you have high
temperatures that usually gives you a
thinner a lower air density right so how
do how do these climactic factors matter
and the stadium is open if I remember
correctly right they have open stadia in
fact they're going to be air
conditioning these there's one there's
one Stadium that's got a roof
yeah I think the others the others even
the ones that are open uh they're
they're still air conditioned yeah even
though they're open uh yeah well thanks
a lot uh the Earth thanks you you don't
know
wait shock wait wait just let's let's
settle this
um
do you remember and it's still the case
you can go to a grocery store and he'll
be a an open
surface of refrigerated items and you'd
reach in and pull it out because the
cold air stays there
okay it's denser than the air you're
breathing five six feet above it yeah so
it's gonna it's a cold air Falls it
stays it's not as energy inefficient as
it might seem I got you but you're still
better off if you cover it right get me
wrong but if you have a stadium and
their air conditioner the air is not
going to fly out of the stadium it's
going to stay right where everybody is
you're absolutely right I mean that's
why yeah yeah I mean I'm but let me just
like let me get buy-in Eric we agree on
that
we we agree on that and and we also
agree that if we're going to play the
World Cup in in Cutter that we better do
it in November and December that's not
in July yeah
uh now at what temperature does this
ball melt because
see the thing is it's what I understand
it gets to about 125 degrees there in
the summertime so thank God we're
playing it in in November the
interesting thing Chuck uh you'll you'll
like this one of the stadium is made
from something like 700 and something
containers and once the tournament is
finished that will be dismantled and
then brought out into others so that as
much as you say that's that's a
contentious place they are making some
effort to address
the sustainability and uh
reusability of products and materials
you know listen I I don't have I guess I
do I have a real problem with the whole
thing no no I'm I'm not I'm not here to
excuse for anybody saying that's the
fact I was I was going to try to go
along to get along but I got a real
problem with the whole thing you know I
got a real problem with FIFA I have a
serious problem uh the same problem with
the Olympic Committee the iocc I I just
I feel as though uh the amount of
corruption that goes into moving these
games around the world is
um just unacceptable it's untenable it
leads to a side thing of resources
unnecessarily so uh it leads to an
incredible amount of waste
um and 330 billion dollars went in to a
few weeks of of this game I understand
it's the most popular game in the world
but uh 330 billion dollars went into
sports watching uh to try to give a
reputation to a country that should not
enjoy any type of reputation and the
same thing was tried in Germany under
Hitler and thank God for one black man
that ruined his plans and um we are
seeing we we see this happen all the
time I just think that it's a it's time
for us to come up with a different model
it's a different model so Eric what's
the physics of that what's the effects
of what don't forget
1934 World Cup went to Mussolini's Italy
so they've been doing this a while yeah
I think I think people in the eight
people have come out and said that uh
the World Cup in Qatar was a mistake and
I think that's come from the higher-ups
in in FIFA yeah it's not just talking
about uh Qatar dog I'm I'm no no I can
see I can see the point you're making
about the grand scheme of how things are
how business is conducted and you know I
just feel as though you know they need
to really start at the top the fish rots
from the head uh they need to start at
the top they need to remove uh you know
the people who are
um running these sanctioning bodies and
they need to come up with a new model
and a model that most of all uh has an
eye towards sustainability because I
think it is
um I'll say the number one
um focus uh in the world where we could
turn our Collective lens towards making
a difference uh when it comes to the
most compelling existential threat that
mankind has ever faced and that might
sound hyperbolic but it really isn't
well we're going to get our chance in
four years Chuck when when North America
is hosting yeah uh oh I'm sorry wait
wait
I wasn't up on that who's who's hosts in
so it's cat it's am I right Eric uh
Canada Mexico and the USA very nice
Canada it's a continental yes a world
cup very nice yeah well and next year
the Women's World Cup will be in
Australia and New Zealand and you know
be interesting to see you know they have
some pretty uh science uh Savvy leaders
down yes it'd be nice to see uh uh you
know what ardern and others are going to
be doing for that World Cup I think New
Zealand will do a great job and I think
that they'll actually take the
responsibility of having the world's
eyes on New Zealand and use that as a
means of being able to further the
message that we all need to do something
not ask not as convinced about Australia
to be honest just to be clear Chuck I
don't mean to interrupt your public
service announcements but but I know I
know people right now watching the show
like where what where are the jokes
when Chuck become NPR Central
no so screw your conscientiousness Chuck
right yeah we right so just to be clear
yes the World Cup is every four years
yes uh and I didn't know they split the
men's and the women so that means yeah
that means every uh two out of every
four years right there's a World Cup
there's an Olympics one out of every
four years there's a winter Olympics one
out of every four years right which
tells us we have four such occasions in
four years to drive whatever Global
message we want that's right so I don't
know that it's
it's you know to put the full weight of
a public service announcement on one
country in one year I think it does not
do justice to the fact that the world
does get together more than this more
than on this occasion oh no that would
set my my point that was my point is
that I have a problem as I said with the
entire scheme it's it's not just these
games like I said it's been going on you
know the the sports watching I have a
problem with that's been going on since
Hitler but uh what I really have a
problem with is the entire scheme of how
businesses conducted how countries are
selected
um and uh the fact that there is no
acknowledgment that hey we have Global
problems and this is a perfect
opportunity to acknowledge our Global
problems and then Collective Solutions I
would say Chuck uh just because I like
reading and studying history I would say
that there were many years several years
of the 20th century where there was no
International competition at all because
we were at a World War correct so so I
think we should at least celebrate the
fact that countries can get together and
do this at all
yeah there is that now guess what that I
can't argue with I can't argue with that
can't argue with that the fact that we
come together and that you know this is
a means of you know as you would put a
friendly competition that's it that's a
start okay see Chuck Tio to your point
um we have younger generation now that
is
intimately focused on sustainability
and they are going to they are going to
be the audience that these governing
bodies are going to hope to harvest for
their hard-earned money okay that
audience for me will be the driving
force for you know what we'll turn up
we'll buy the product we'll buy you 180
football or whatever it is however I
want this this this this and this box
ticked and I want this done and this
done and this done and this will then
have to be brought to bear on location
on bids on everything else that goes
into making an event like the world cup
or the Summer Olympics that's yeah
that's my thinking but big Chuck
mentioned the 330 billion dollars not
enough of that went to those migrant
workers whose backs this these cities
were built and Stadium hotels and stuff
I mean there's another Point very uh
horrific working conditions for those
those people yeah
so Eric what's the what's the physics of
all that
what the physics is I think is that we
need to spend more time learning science
and less time focused on 7th Century
superstitions how about that oh
um
Eric that was uh that's not that's not
the only Century from which people no or
first century or keep on going yes I
think yeah I mean think about I don't
think there's a century without there's
not a century without that's right
however there's not a century without
but in this particular Century it makes
it that much more egregious because come
on all right guys we gotta we gotta wrap
this but I want to get like one sentence
wrap from each of you Chuck give me one
sentence uh you know I just think um
if it's a beautiful game let's make it
that for uh you know 360. you know if
it's a beautiful game let's make it
beautiful in every aspect and that means
that uh you know we shouldn't have uh
slavery
um involved to create uh the conditions
under which the games can be played we
shouldn't have corruption that uh allows
for the politics uh one sentence truck
okay sorry now moving on all right damn
that's the longest PSA I have ever heard
okay let me just end with uh I love
soccer no thanks fine
uh Gary I hope the new ball enhances the
game and we get more goals and more
entertainment and people go away happy
and uh the love for the game grows
excellent and Eric take us out so enjoy
the sporting moments and excitement you
feel and please remember you could feel
just as much excitement from the science
behind everything you're watching
Hallelujah I love it I love it that is
one of our threads of our DNA is the
science in the culture yeah all right
guys it's been great to have you back uh
Eric we got to call it quits there this
has been star talk sports edition FIFA
World Cup special Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist keep
looking up